[Music]
all right it's uh nice to meet you
thanks for having me thanks for doing
this really excited to talk to you I
think of you as part of this trifecta
that includes KJ Dell Antonia just Leahy
and yourself as three women who are
doing really important work around
parenting and you're really in the sweet
spot of what currently interests me the
most as a koozie parents of an
adolescent girl fifteen year old
daughter and an 11 year old daughter and
I'm going to have to resist the urge to
try to make this all about me and my you
know parenting issues out of respect for
my daughter and her privacy but I may
lapse into that at times but really
excited to talk to you about this very
important and interesting and dramatic
period in young girls lives that I'm
currently in the midst of experiencing
at the moment and I think the best way
to maybe kick into it I'd like to hear
your thoughts on how we as a culture and
maybe as parents think about this period
of adolescence in girls lives I feel
like and I know you've addressed this in
your book that we've sort of
pathologized this you know Oh be careful
you know when your daughter turns 13 or
14 or 15 everything changes and it's you
know she's gonna become a quote unquote
monster and you know just get ready okay
I am in complete agreement so three
years ago I published a book called
untangled guiding teenage girls through
the seven transitions into adulthood and
the first line of that book is we need a
new way to talk about teenage girls
because the way we do it now isn't fair
to girls or helpful to their parents and
I go on to describe exactly what you
just described you know that people say
like oh you know because I do I have two
daughters people see me with them and
they say oh I'm so glad I have boys
right or when people will learn what I
do professionally you know that I I take
care of teenagers for you know a living
and teenage girls in particular
they'll say like oh there should be
medals for that they're the worst you
know so there is all of this sort of bad
press around adolescent girls
I think teenagers in general I think
girls in boys each get their own bad rap
you know I think it's specific to gender
and it is so unhelpful and so
unnecessary and I do feel like my main
aim in my professional work is to try to
help people understand the normal
vicissitudes of adolescence and in
untangled my previous commercial book I
do walk through all of these expectable
transitions and I end every chapter with
a section called when to worry because
so much of normal development is
challenging that I wanted parents to
know that there actually is a line you
can cross but you know most of what you
see is difficult but normal and with
response to that book the the thing that
so many people have said to me that has
meant the world to me as they say it
feels like you're in our house it feels
like you've had a bug uh-huh on us which
I hear them as saying we thought we were
the only ones it's such a breath of
fresh air to hear this is normal
development all right this is a pattern
that people are living with what is it
that's specific to girls that makes it
different from raising boys at this age
so I think 80% of what I say about girls
probably also applies to boys and I hear
that repeatedly from readers of both
books they'll say you know I bought it
from my daughter an 80% applied to it my
son and certainly my work on the
structure of adolescence the transitions
I laid out in untangled boys go through
the same exact transitions there are
unique pressures facing girls and that's
why I do homed in on them in my book
length work I think that there are
cultural expectations the girls are held
to that boys don't have to worry about
quite so much I know boys worry about
their appearance I don't think they do
it at nearly the level the girls no of
course are asked by the culture to worry
about it girls more than boys the
research tells us you know they worry
about what adults think you know they're
very concerned about disappointing
adults this adds a whole other layer of
pressure in their lives at school and at
home
in under-pressure my new book chapter 4
is about girls among boys and the sexual
dynamics between girls and boys are not
something adults want to look at all
that closely and they're not that great
and and I think there's a lot of work
that we need to be doing on behalf of
kids but I think for both boys actually
and girls but I also think first we have
to you know well how are we I mean yeah
you've broken the book up into kind of
sections like girls at home girls at
school girls with boys girls in the
culture what is it we you know since you
raised that this issue now girls with
boys maybe we can just talk about that
right now I mean what is it that we're
misunderstanding as parents about this
or maybe afraid to talk about so I think
there's a few pieces um I talked about
this in this chapter you know the the
amount of harassment girls are dealing
with by middle school is pretty stunning
and it's casual and it's just part of
the school day for a lot of girls it's
supported by research documenting this
kind of harassment but it's you know
guys calling them and and
then if they push back the guys will be
like oh I was just kidding you know
you're making a big deal of it there was
an extraordinary study by done by the
American Association of University Women
I'm called hostel hallways and it
documented by eighth grade half of girls
had dealt with you know boys drawing
drawing penises on their notebooks boys
threatening spread rumors about them
boys talking about their boobs to them
boys you know saying all of this stuff
is sort of um I think for a lot of girls
just seen as part of what you have to
deal with in the course of a school day
would I worry and this is the piece
where I feel like there's a lot of work
to be done I'm not sure I'm the one
who's gonna do this work but I think the
work needs to be done what I worry is
that if you're a sixth grade boy the
shortest route to social power maybe
acting like a jerk mm-hmm either through
homophobic behavior or it's basically
chauvinistic behavior and you know sixth
grade boys and sixth grade girls you
know they are really just figuring it
out as they go they are not who they're
going to be but I do worry that it would
be easy enough
for a sixth-grade boy to strike upon
realizing that if he calls that kid a
or if he calls that girl a all
of this power flows his way and the
power is because now kids are scared of
him and once you're a sixth or seventh
grader the people are scared of people
actually want to be close to you because
they don't want to be a potential target
so I worry that there's this juncture
much earlier in development that we're
usually looking at that can set guys on
a path that they should not be on they
don't want to be on I think I'd like to
think they don't want to be on and that
also means that girls are putting up
with all sorts of nonsense that should
not be part of their day and that's the
part where I feel like adults have when
we're talking about the me2 movement
where I think we're talking about it way
later than is relevant to my work right
that doesn't start to impact culture
until a generation later it's
interesting because I was that was my
sort of thinking while you were talking
was how has this if it has it all
changed in the wake of the Weinstein
scandal and the me2 movement and the
conversations that we're having around
toxic masculinity and in my experience
you know at a very very much at arm's
length is that I'm seeing boys doing
that stuff and it doesn't seem to be
changing its totally divorced from
what's happening at the adult level
there was an interesting report last
week in I think it was in Bethesda there
was a boy who was the ringleader at a
high school then several of the boys who
had created a ranking system for girls
law I went to I went to school in
Bethesda yeah and this came out and the
school did not as far as the girls
involved were concerned discipline him
adequately and I think 40 girls showed
up in the principal's office and just
you know we're absolutely incensed about
it that's new dad is new that so that to
answer your question I think that that
piece feels to me like behavior might
not have changed but the reaction and
the response to that a havior has
changed and that was exciting to see and
and they've forced the hand of the
administration and became a much bigger
deal there was much more sort of a you
know reckoning around what had occurred
so I do feel like okay
great we're getting the trickle-down
into high school in this one story I
think sixth grade is ground zero and I
think that's the place where grown-ups
are pretty comfortable going with the
idea that we we don't need to think
about it so young and if we're gonna
talk about it let's talk about it you
know a lot of kids have said you're
looking at porn yeah you know and and
dan Savage you know who loves you I love
Dan Savage you know what he says he says
porn hates women you know and and I
think that certainly what kids are
accessing you know they're not looking
at erotica you know they're not looking
at soft focus you know romantic stuff
I think Dan's right you know I think
it's and that is thoroughly supported in
the research literature you know the the
way academic psychologists say it is a
you know coalesce is around themes of
degradation and violence this is sex ed
for a lot of kids yeah it's really
supplanted yeah how we used to teach
young people about these things and it's
become their roadmap and their guidebook
for what sexual interaction should look
like and if we want to talk about
pathology I mean that's a massive
pathology it is and it does feel like to
me one of those things where the girls
are pretty glad to be like you know just
to not confront what it means that 11
and 12 year olds who are of course
curious about sex right I mean like
that's not the problem is that when
they're curious about sex are going to
pornhub.com and seeing stuff there that
blows adults out of the water to look at
and our girls doing the same so it's
interesting when we look at the research
we see a I think it's something like by
the end of high school seventy percent
of girls have seen porn what becomes
interesting as you drill down and I
don't have the numbers exactly is
whether they're initiating though
looking at the porn or whether as often
happens they're riding the bus and some
kid pulls it up on their phone and goes
hey look at this you know it'll stick
sit in their face so I think they're
singing it girls are curious about sex
too so I'm sure some of them are seeing
it and and pursuing it and I I have a 15
year old daughter and I like you and
cautious about talking about her but
this I can share because it's what I
said to her when she was in seventh
grade
she started with that you know I'd like
a phone I'd like a phone and we went on
a walk around the block and I said you
know here's my number-one concern
not that you're gonna be unkind not that
you're gonna use this for you know to
distract yourself or get in the way or
sleep my number one concern is this is a
likely vehicle by which you will
ultimately be exposed to pornography and
I want to say a few words to you before
that happens like so what you sorry so
what I said is I think it's gonna really
freak you out I think it's gonna really
freak you out and I want you to bear in
mind that the sex that you see in a
commercial environment people are paid
for sex you know they're being paid to
to have sex on camera I said to her I
believe it's fundamentally exploitive I
that is not loving romantic sex I want
to reassure you what you're seeing on
porn that is not really have a lot in
common with the love life I've ever had
and I said to her I think a lot of us
gonna strike you as violent and weird
and that's actually not what sex needs
to be about it's not what it's about for
me and when the day comes that you see
porn I didn't say if when the day comes
that you see porn one way or another I'm
here to answer any questions you've got
it means you're gonna have a lot of
questions yeah and what happens when
that young girl is in the midst of her
first or an early sexual encounter with
a boy who has been looking at porn for a
long time and is taking all of his cues
from basically what he's seen in those
videos well here's what the data say the
data say this that porn scripts are in
fact shaping sexual scripts they have to
be they are and a lot of it it's
interesting has been the change in the
rates of anal sex you know that that has
now you know we've been tracking this
over time and and you know the rates
have really increased and you know III
approaches this interesting both sort of
non-judgmentally as a psychologist I
sort of feel like you know what people's
sexual lives like I'm not gonna
legislate adults sexual lives when we
look at the data a lot of women don't
enjoy anal sex you know and and so yet a
lot of guys because of the porn scripts
that are so prominent
under the impression that this is a sort
of a standard right part of the menu
right what are we gonna do about that I
think they're going to need to take
their fingers out of their ears a minute
and take their hands off their eyes and
and have more more honest conversations
with their kids it's interesting cuz
again i I'm I'm really very kind of
relaxed and liberal or about a lot of
stuff but I I do think it's interesting
that we have no regulation mm-hmm on
this it's also funny to me I've been
vaping is bad like I'm no fan of vaping
and I know grown-ups are really on the
ceiling about vaping I am less on the
ceiling about vaping than I think a lot
of grown-ups are and I use a lavaridge I
won't come back to that yeah but it is
interesting cuz I was I in my community
I'm aware of like this panel on vaping
and this panel on you know and I'm like
we should have this much on porn like we
should have agree there should be this
much well I think we're afraid yeah you
know it's just it's too freaky to talk
about it's something that you know we
don't feel comfortable talking about out
in the open and that just foments the
pathology of it I think that's right
yeah and so we're like all right kids
you guys go over there and deal with
that we're just gonna look the other way
in but the vaping thing is tricky
because it can be so clandestine it's so
easy to hide it and it's so difficult to
detect it and it's so enticing for
people at that age it's pretty sexy
right I mean it's really a pretty good
way to do something your parents really
don't want you to do right which is a
lot of what getting to be teenagers
about um okay so vaping is not good and
okay I want to be clear that I am NOT a
not a fan of vaping um it my number one
concern is obviously the kids are
getting addicted to nicotine so now
they're getting themselves caught on a
substance that they you know where this
is not an addiction that goes away
easily there the jury is out on
questions of you know that the long
impact of microparticles are you know
vaporized formaldehyde but you know what
I say to kids and what I've written is
like why risk it right like why hate
risk it um the reason I am a little more
I'm not I'm
not as on the ceiling above vaping I
think as other adults is I'm a mindful
of how it is received by teenagers when
adults seem to be equally terrified of
everything so when I talk with teenagers
too hard in the pecking order it's a
little high so when I talk with
teenagers and I spend a lot of time
talking with teenagers about you know
the various hazards out there I will say
to them you know now using my hand I'll
say like okay so heroines up here you
know and I will extend my arm above my
head to its fullest length right and
cocaine is right there and you know any
other drug that you someone's giving you
have no idea what it is like it's up
there and marijuana is up here and I'll
tell you you know it's it's lower than
these in terms of and I'm thinking
surely in terms of biological risk
hazards right like I I say to them the
law is super complicated and immaterial
you're not gonna get caught it's really
about the the physical hazards and then
I'll say in cigarette smoking you know
is here you know sort of at a mid range
leaving everything we know biologically
is below cigarette smoking in terms of
its real risks right and you know
obviously kids today are not smoking a
ton of cigarettes so we don't have
reasons to be holding lots of panels
about that but then I say to them
usually you don't want to be messing
with any of this stuff right all of
these are psychoactive all of these are
biological all of these will have a
negative impact on your body
none of these you know I'll say to them
like get crazy haircuts like we're you
know tacky nails like do something don't
do something that has a potential for
lasting consequences these all do and
what I find that seems to sit right with
teenagers but when we talk about vaping
with the same energy and anxiety that we
talked about the heroin epidemic I think
then to teenagers they feel like the
teenagers know it's not equally
dangerous and then I think we've become
pretty dismissible in those moments yeah
I mean certainly there's a difference
between opioids and nicotine vaping or
marijuana for that matter but you know
here in California there's such a
mainstreaming of marijuana like it's
almost perceived as like part of your
wellness equation now with CBD and all
these sorts of things and
we've had a real huge cultural shift in
how we perceive that that alarms me to
some extent as somebody who's a long
time in recovery first of all and you
know carries that genetic you know
predisposition that's passed down but I
think the way young people perceive it
is different than when I was you know of
that age where it's like it's just no
big deal and you know their brains are
still developing and you know certainly
you know you could speak to the that
issue more eloquently than I could but
to kind of look at it like it's like
it's nothing isn't the solution either
no no and actually so you know the issue
for me with marijuana is the
neurological impact right and and what
we know is that at least till age 24 25
there's a real neurological impact of
marijuana because of the developing
brain and there's some extraordinary
research that came out of do Nadine I
don't know if I'm pronouncing it
correctly I think in Australia where
they these researchers started measuring
an entire cohort everybody born in a
single year and they did this about 40
years ago and they just kept measuring
this group over and over and over again
every year and they have the data on the
kids who started using pot really
heavily in high school and they were
taking IQ data all the time and what
they found was that kids who were using
a lot so not like the occasional
everyone's from an experiment the kids
who are using a lot I my recollection is
they lost about 10 IQ points and even
when they stopped using the IQ points
did not return they didn't bounce back
yeah there was just alright and so when
I talk with teenagers about marijuana I
say like you're the data this will cost
you your some of your intelligence it
also in the day to day and and kids have
observed this in their peers it makes
kids fuzzy whether or not they're high
in that moment there is a bit of a
hangover that lasts and and so I say to
them like look at you're really talking
about changing your trajectory here
right you really if you get yourself
involved with this it could have real
meaning so I'm in Ohio I live in in Ohio
where marijuana is not legal and yet
interestingly kids feel like it is like
that's the other thing that's striking
to me is that
and I sometimes will find myself a
really thoughtful 18 year old and just
check I'll say like maybe not marijuana
I like it like that's illegal I'll say
like what it's like basically good right
and I thought because everybody's
information died is not localized yeah
so I'm like but you know it's not here
they're like but basically isn't it no
but really it's not but I've been
interested how even these really
thoughtful kids they do they dig they
take it at the national level so what I
say to the kids I take care of an Ohio
unlike look if it is your lifelong dream
to smoke pot like if you feel like you
have to do this before you die the only
really safe way to consider doing this
is you go to a place where it is legal
you get it through a legal channel and
you do it after age 25 right again and
then you could try it and then I say
you're still impaired I mean it's not
like you're you know ready to go do
something that requires any good
judgment but I do try to make the point
like there are real health consequences
that have nothing to do with where the
law sets the age I mean the law doesn't
make sense if we're looking at it from
the health perspective there's a large
gap between what's actually going on in
this demographic and how you know what
parents think is going on and how media
portrays what's going on like here's an
example I took my daughter to go see
that movie 8th grade yeah and I thought
oh we're gonna have this great
experience we're gonna have you know
she's gonna she's gonna see her own
interior and exterior life reflected on
the big screen in this honest way and
she she hated the movie she's like yeah
I kind of get it but this is such a
dishonest portrayal of what it's
actually like she felt like it was
completely whitewashed she said nobody's
doing drugs nobody's looking at porn
nobody's vaping nobody's listening to
hip-hop like all of the things that are
part of her daily experience were
completely eradicated from that
depiction and I think there's an honesty
in that actresses portrayal that story
like I think there's a lot of truth in
that movie but my point is that she
didn't see her own were her own
experience reflected in that movie she
likes to see see movies like kids you
know which is super invocation
we went and saw mid-90s that's like her
favorite movie because she felt like
there's an authenticity and like an
unabashed anise tea about how kids you
know think about their lives at that
period of time and she did see her her
her experience reflected in those movies
because they're grittier and darker and
all that but I guess the point I'm
making is I think there's there's more
complexity and darkness and nuance than
we as parents or the culture would like
to accept or embrace and what how do you
think about that or respond to that in
general I agree right I mean I think
that we we sort of pick and choose what
we want to engage with about adolescence
experience and and I think it's easy for
us to look away from some things what's
interesting there's two ways to think
about this when we just think about it
from a research-based perspective one is
the data are consistently showing this
is the best-behaved generation of
teenagers on record really yeah yeah
they do fewer drugs than their parents
did they buy the safety measures we do
you know things like using contraception
wearing seatbelts wearing helmets
drinking they actually binge drink less
than previous generation think that's
true so by a great number of safety and
risk-taking metrics this is a very
conservative generation they have much
less sex they have sex later you know
all of these things and and one of the
hypotheses is actually the digital
technology's taking up a lot of the
space uh-huh right so kids used to get
together and have sex now they stay home
and sext you know so that's taken that
up and there was one piece I read in The
Times awhile back
where some of the hypotheses about kids
doing fewer drugs was around well
they're you know they're hooked on their
phones you know so and part of me that
was that's the primary addiction yeah
you know like I'm not sure I'm not okay
with that
um so the first thing I think I always
want to get out there on the table is
like as a group they're actually good
kids right and then as a group they're
definitely better behaved than we were
generationally the other thing
that comes into it and this is I think
maybe your surprise the kids who are in
the fast lane everybody knows who they
are and what they're doing right that
they're very they get a lot of press in
in adolescent social circles and we do
studies where we look at kids
assumptions of who's doing what and how
much of it right so if we ask kids how
many kids are smoking they call it weed
right how many kids were smoking weed
you know there their estimates are much
much higher than the reality because the
kids who are smoking weed are talking
about it everyone knows who they are
same thing with sex same thing even one
of the things I talked about it under
pressure is the that cut the hook-up
scene
right so it turns out the data actually
don't support the hype of the hook-up
scene that it's what is the height so
the height is the college is one big
orgy right and if you're gonna do
college right you're gonna be having you
know sex with strangers pretty often
right
that's not to say that doesn't happen
but in terms of again estimates and kids
you know presumptions of how many kids
are doing this versus how many kids are
actually doing it they're these big big
gaps so in no way to diminish that your
daughter's experience like these things
are around me you know these things are
in my existence and that's that's no
small thing right to be mindful of kids
you know that kids smoking weed that
kids having sex I mean like they're
they're well aware of these things
my favorite way for adults to engage
that is to think out loud with their
kids about what percentage of their
overall class are we talking here
because often it's a much it's a fairly
small percentage of kids who are
thoroughly in the fast lane right but
they're the ones that everyone's
watching on snapchat yeah right
yeah they're getting the attention they
are there's some really lovely I'm not
gonna remember the name of the group
that does this which bothers me there is
a group it may be freedom from chemical
dependency and their work with
adolescents around drug and alcohol use
is actually to show them the base rates
in their own school I think they do
surveys
I hope I'm getting this right this may
not be accurate
where they do surveys and they've
actually then present to the kids you
know what only 20% of the kids in your
school I've ever tried and for a lot of
kids this is a revelation and they aim
in that group if that's the right group
is to actually help them appreciate that
you're probably in the majority if
you're not use them right because kids
can feel marginal when so much process
going to the kids who are what is the
reality of well first of all like what
is hookup culture you know like maybe we
should define that and how boys and
girls are interacting in this way or
girls and girls are boys and boys in a
way that might maybe is different from
the generation that preceded it so here
the data it is true that this generation
is more likely than their parents
generation to have intercourse with
someone who's a friend rather they don't
it's not part of a romantic relationship
so I guess they would call like friends
and relatives wasn't kind of casual that
that that is the one place in the data
where we see this generations patterns
maybe being I don't know what the term
is you know like more liberal than their
parents where compared to the past
generation they are having less sex they
are having fewer partners they're having
sex later so you know the you know
spring breaker movies would have you
believe that like we're in some new age
of you know you know sexual deccan al
the data don't support that huh that's
interesting yeah I wouldn't I wouldn't
have thought that I know and so it was
interesting then and the reason I make a
point of talking about it and under
pressure is since that's the story I
have had girls come see me and say I
don't really think I'm ready for college
like I don't I just can't see myself
participating in what sounds like the
landscape there and and I feel like I'm
doing all of this work or saying that's
actually not the landscape like you can
find real relationships right you do not
have to assume that if you're gonna have
a love life it's gonna be this you know
drive my situation and again to try to
normalize that that
this is one one corner of what's going
on but it's not the whole story right
and what about during the high school
years so most of the data I'm aware over
looking at more at college same though
high schoolers are having sex later and
having fewer partners than previous
generations and and again it's that
there they're just often not with each
other while they're communicating yeah
you know I mean we had to go to
someone's house yeah right so hang out
what I've noticed with with what's
interesting is I have two of our boys
that are 24 and 23 now and they they're
very analog like they don't they're
really not mean they have Instagram
accounts they barely ever post like they
live very you know IRL lives but my
daughters are very different and one of
the things I've noticed that they do
it's interesting how a technology will
come online and then you see a younger
generation adopt it and use it in ways
that you would never have imagined or
anticipated so they both use FaceTime
they face time with their friends not to
like have a short call but they just
leave it on just to be they'll be in
there yeah like they're basically with
their even when they're in their bedroom
they'll be like four hours and they're
not even talking to each other they're
just sort of in this communal virtual
virtual space with each other while
they're doing a other thing homework
yeah I'm like I would have never
imagined that and I see that over and
over and over again so yeah they're
there together but they're not they are
um and they're together a lot right I
mean like I mean there were times
eventually we were just cut off right
like our moms that like get off the
phone anyway and then you had you know
10 to 12 hours at least where you were
just separated from your friends just
because you had to be there together a
lot and there's a beautiful quote from
Dana Boyd whose academic who studies
kids in technology and does it in a
really thoughtful way and and her quote
is you know they're not addicted to the
technology they're addicted to each
other mm-hmm you know and I think that
that really like they just want to be
together you know I want to be together
all the time that's very kind of
reassuring to me yeah yeah like there's
there's actually nothing wrong with that
that's a yearning for connection
the other thing I say all time to
parents is if we had the technology our
kids had we would have used it as they
use it of course I mean like we would
have killed for it
really and-and-and when parents sort of
seemed to be hesitant to accept that
then I'll say next do you remember the
feeling on your ear when you had had the
phone on it for so long that it hurt you
know and you were talking to somebody
and you would say um hold on wait I have
to switch sides a degree and that that
was us you know we did what we could
with what we had what we had was very
lame compared what they have well I feel
like we have to make we can't just blue
you know Luke put all of technology in
one bucket and then just say it's this
one thing like I look at it like this
very powerful highly addictive
you know toolbox or you know
receivership for your attention that can
be productive and enriching or can be
very destructive so if you're spending
time creating like trying to make a
really cool photograph or edit a video
like then you're in a creative mode or
if you're on FaceTime with your friends
and you're you're you know having an
exchange with that person then you're
involved in connection but then there's
just the addictive mindless scrolling
through Facebook or you know Instagram
story not Facebook kids don't use
Facebook Instagram stories or snapchat
where you're just consuming other
people's lives and I think there's a
real kind of darkness built into that in
terms of how myself included I lump
myself in this how it makes us feel
about ourselves in comparison to others
and and the impact of that on a young
developing mind where your social status
and your how you kind of fit into this
web at school and outside of school is
like life or death for young people yeah
and with you I do think it's actually
helpful I've been a practicing
psychologist for more than 20 years and
so I started practicing when this did
not have any part in family life and
then I watched the arc of it
and one thing that is easier now than it
was before is if the parents are pretty
fluent themselves with hell they get
caught up with technology you know with
Facebook and Twitter and looking at
stuff and I do too I do too
I'm and I'm mindful of how it comes into
my life and so it's there was a juncture
I would say about maybe 15 years ago
where kids had MySpace and parents had
no idea what any of this was and had
never interacted with it at all so that
was actually in some ways more difficult
because the kids were so far ahead of
the grown up so grown-ups are a little
closer than they used to be theirs are
the topic of attention I'm how it gets
hijacked right and then there's a topic
of what you're looking at here's a way
to think about it we have always in
schools done things like media literacy
right like look at this magazine what is
that model you know how much does that
been altered and all of that okay kids
are not looking at magazines anymore
right definitely
the lesson though is basically the same
right like everything's a message
everything's telling you something
everything is crafted in a particular
way and so what we can do right is we
can just think like okay well this is
the media right it's if they're creating
it but this is essentially media that
they're looking at now and we want them
to be as literate about it as possible
right so there's great work done by a
woman named Jill Walsh who's an academic
who looks at talking with kids about
what they see on social media and her
guidance is to have them you know if
they're scrolling on their Instagram to
say to them how many pictures do you
think she took to choose that one and
tell me about that pose like what's that
for what's that about you know they're
not judging but getting them to take a
critical eye and not consume it
wholesales the analogy I use an
under-pressure
is that everything you see on social
media that people post it's like a
furniture showroom and our own lives are
actually like lived in homes and we know
our own lives we're only seeing the
furniture showroom but we can't help but
compare them right and of course of
course the furniture showrooms always
gonna look better because it's not lived
in and we need to say that to kids all
the time that doesn't mean it fully
buffers the impact but we need to get
that filter in there if we can yes so
rather than
shaming them or telling them to put it
down or to stop doing whatever they're
doing to just in a dispassionate neutral
way educate as best as we can about the
ramifications of it I mean that's
essentially what you're saying I think
so yeah and I just ask a lot of
questions right I don't you know like oh
you know that girl like she's really
bright right like that's that she's not
that's not part of the story she's
telling with that picture you know I
mean to really just keep that
conversation going
um as much as we can without annoying
them too much you know so that they they
don't want to have it at all are there
studies that look at how this is
impacting young minds versus adult minds
so the truth is we just don't have the
data right I mean so to do those kinds
of studies in some ways it's basically
impossible right because we would have
to do like case-control and Ranma Simon
and all of that and and it's important
to know that because there are some
pretty scary headlines right there are
headlines out there about you know
smartphones doing all this damage to
kids we don't really have the data to be
able to save anything like that
conclusively um I will say that if
there's anything I think parents should
be working at worrying about I would
actually just put sleep at the top of
the list at the absolute top of the list
um this is a very boring it's very
simple explanation for kids being
stressed and fragile and anxious but
sleep is the glue that holds human
beings together and our kids get way
less sleep than they need you know
social media is a big piece of that
mm-hmm so I'd worry about sleep I would
worry about the capacity to focus right
we don't we know that you really the
capacity to focus is a muscle that you
build I think and I've got suggestions I
can make about like how we help kids
learn to set Technology aside when it's
time to do focused work and I would
worry about the capacity to have
one-on-one conversations to be with
people and present and and not
distracted by technology the rest I
think it's here to stay
yeah you know well I don't think that we
fully appreciate the power and the
impact that this is having on all of us
not just kids I mean never in the
history of humanity have we had such a
powerful device
that is so perfectly attuned to
magnetize our attention in the most
addictive way and you know we can sort
of Slough it off or just say well this
is the way it is now but like if you
really step back and look at it it's
incredibly powerful and there's just no
way that there aren't I'm you know
unbelievably impactful downstream
impacts from this I think I think we'll
find that yeah I do you think laughs I
think we're just beginning to kind of
appreciate it and hopefully we're going
to learn more I mean there's interesting
people doing a lot of compelling work
around you know the addictive nature of
these things and you know the data
mining and all of that of course but I
think we still have a lot to learn I
think I'm with you all the way um I feel
like this thing got so far out ahead of
us and took us all over and we're just
now yeah it starting to look Cal Newport
is doing some interesting work is just
sitting there Oh two weeks ago so you
know I think there's smart people coming
through and it's probably a piece about
this and the times like everyday you
don't know about ways to manage one's
focus but I do think you know I just I'm
not one really - I don't want parents
parenting from a position of fear like I
really think it goes better or goes over
better to say look it's not that I'm
against technology it's a time for sleep
I'm for your capacity to focus I'm for
your ability to sit here with me to have
a conversation without picking up your
phone so I'm gonna fiercely protect
those because those are what I'm on the
side of and that's gonna mean you can't
have the technology around all the time
yeah and that's a tricky conversation to
have when you're used to having that
technology in your hand at all times to
create a healthy boundary around it to
protect that sleep I mean this is
something you know we've gone through
and the focus piece I think is even
trickier because young minds have grown
up with these devices and they're used
to being stimulated from five different
vectors at the same time and I just
noticed like how young people do their
homework they've got a laptop with a
television show on they've got snapchat
open they're playing music and they've
got a notebook out that they're writing
on and all of these things are happening
at the same time and I'm like
how you can focus on anything like like
now this is this is how we do it now
and so myself as a parent I'm in the
position of trying to lay down the law
and say no you have to do it the way
that I did it and the way that I think
it should be done or do I say well we'll
see how this goes when your grades come
and then we'll adjust hmm
I think they both could work I want you
to know cognitive science has your back
mmm because there's no such thing as
multitasking effectively yeah
humans only have so much bandwidth
anything you do that distracts you is
chewing up bandwidth there's no extra
bandwidth so if I'm reading and I'm
listening to music some of that
bandwidth is being taken to work music
so the easiest thing right this is this
is not not encouraging people with older
kids is to get way out in front of it
right to have homework habits be
established with your first grader like
this is something you do yeah in the
dining room you don't you wait until
they're fit to start it and actually and
one of my friends did this great thing
when she had kids so she lives in
Pennsylvania in a two-story home and the
bedrooms are on the second floor and her
rule was you know no phone don't go up
no technology ever goes to the second
house ever
yeah and we ever ruled actually I'm a
really flexible parent but I have a no
technology in any bedroom ever in the 24
hour day rule so I think it's easier if
parents get out in front of it yeah but
if you haven't if you haven't one thing
that parents can do that sort of a maybe
a compromise between what you're
suggesting is to ask for an experiment
to ask for an experiment say like can we
do a week where you do it with all your
stuff away and see how it feels and see
how it goes and see if it goes faster
wait how did that go over you're gonna
pry that thing out of my hand when you
know it's cold and dead yeah you know it
comes very emotionally heightened yeah
so maybe that's when you wait for the
grades to come in yeah and then that you
say like this isn't what you're doing
isn't working we gotta try something
else I think most parents are in the
position of like dealing with it once
it's a problem you know it takes a lot
of
mindfulness and intent and intention to
have a dress that at a very early age
hats off to those parents I think the
common situation is like well this thing
is spiraling out of control like you
know and then we feel like we're doing
damage control and we're in these these
very emotional conversations that then
you know become something else
altogether they do so here's here's
what's encouraging to me I'm watching
smart kids figure this out and I've
heard from teenagers a lot of them have
strategies involving technology for
getting their work done without
technology disrupting it so they tell me
about things like they have their phone
on a timer of 25 minute intervals and
it's near them and they're watching that
tick down and once the 25 interval is
passed they let themselves check for
five minutes and then they go back to
work I'm no but I think this is
brilliant right I mean 25 minutes is
long enough to focus they probably do
need a break I talk about it in under
pressure a bunch of teenage girls over
finals at a girls school actually in LA
gave each other permission to change
each other's passwords on all of the
social media that they found alluring so
that they could not access their own
social media and then fixed it for each
other after finals - so they could have
at school and all sorry that also
involves a lot of trust yeah yeah no
they they but they just they made this
pact and they did that and so one of the
conversations I consult two days a week
at a girls school and Shaker Heights and
so what I have started to do when I want
teenagers to change their behavior is I
will have a whole group of teenagers and
I'll say who has strategies for getting
their homework done without being
distracted by it
and they suddenly four girls in the room
will start talking well I do this I do
this I do this that I find to be a
vastly more effective thing I'm gonna be
rolling in with you guys because it's
self-generated and can they have an
ownership of it it's relevant to them
it's coming from someone who's doing the
same homework they're doing and also the
problem that is just true and
irreducible when we roll up to try to
talk to kids about their technology is
they're like you don't get it you know
you don't get what it means to me and
think that is 100% true and I think it's
very hard for us to take guidance on
something when we feel like the person
trying to offer advice doesn't actually
get experience and so if I can get
teenagers talking to each other about
strategies that for me feels like the
most ideal right because it's not coming
top down from the parents no and they
also know who's getting what grades in
that room yeah you know and I don't know
everything about each other yeah
ompletely yeah in a way that you know we
didn't so it's interesting to have you
know the goal that they all know is
killing it
pipe up and say this is my strategy for
men right right so I think and I do the
same around sleep right because
teenagers are supposed to get nine hours
of sleep at night which very few do and
I've done the same thing I'll get a big
enough group or else okay who here is
getting roughly eight or nine hours a
night and usually there's a couple and
then I will say tell us how you make it
happen right and get them talking that I
have found to be less controlled and
less satisfying than me rolling in with
right you know and all my rules and I
think probably more useful to the
teenagers I'm caring for yeah let's talk
a little bit about the teenage girl
friend matrix versus how kind of boys
navigate their social circles like my
sense is that girls have much more
intense intimate friendships boys tend
to have lots of friends but it's very
casual and you know within the teenage
girl universe it's all about like this
network of friends is like everything
meaning like I said life or death
earlier I mean it really is like the
most important thing like the status in
the group who's doing what how everybody
is interacting and there's a there's a
beautiful intimacy into it but it is so
it's delicate and it's very supercharged
yeah yeah um Wow like where to begin
yeah yeah okay so he teased this yeah
those are pride a little bit well let me
just put on the table there's no
biological reason for boys and girls
to be here differently in their
relational lives what we see is what's
socialized mmm-hmm
and and so I mean I there are all the
difference you just described you know
they do arrive but it's not that boys
are so not built differently than girls
it's just there's some really nice work
done by a woman named Niobe way about
you know the various barriers and also
times when boys do have really deep
intimate relationships with each other
but there's other work Michael Thompson
has done some of it where it's just not
seen as like cool for guys to be
intimate in their friendships and so
then they are socialized away from it
girls here's what we know about girls
versus boys in terms of how they relate
girls when they are just stressed this
this is important are much more likely
just to discuss the fact that they are
distressed so if somebody hurts their
feelings they're likely to find a friend
and discuss this at length boys when
they are hurt are more likely to
distract themselves took a home hop you
know hop on a video game or go out shoot
hoops or something but to just try to
let it die down through distraction and
is that a socialized response normally
socialized but the upshot is that we
start to see exactly what you're
describing which is boys become a little
bit more you know each man's his own
island and he kind of bumps up against
other guys you know based on what
they're doing together whereas girls are
having these you know powerful
conversations about being injured by
so-and-so or you know something's
bothering me I'm gonna find a friend and
talk and this is what we we then couch
as quote-unquote drama drama right right
so that looks like a lot of drama but so
it's not that the boys are not in pain
it's not the boys are not mean to other
boys it's that the response when the
meanness occurs is very different then
another gendered finding shows out which
is the girls more of them boys again
this is socialized are likely to
experience vicarious stress so if my
friend is upset now I'm also upset
because she's upset boys more than girls
again socialized
don't have quite the same transfer like
I'm sorry you're upset good luck with
that right now
so the impact of this this is where you
start to see these really gendered
patterns in terms of like how drama
plays out so let's imagine a single mean
event occurs to a boy into a girl to the
boy he may be in quite a bit of pain and
go home and play video games until the
feeling dies down then we never hear of
it again this isn't great for him right
it means he suffers in silence it means
he doesn't get the support he deserves
but it does kind of go quiet a girl has
a mean event occur she tells three
friends because she's very upset and now
her friends are upset on her behalf so
they're gonna tell other people yeah so
this thing could go on for like three
weeks right they're gonna talk to the
person who perpetrated that gotta make
it right you know so so when we look at
the data it's a cascading yeah right
it's art you know so so it's interesting
and this is actually how girls got the
reputation for being meaner is that when
when there is meanest among girls you
know it's basically spilled all over an
entire you know social circle
statistically boys are meaner you know
which isn't good but in terms of
physical violence rumor spreading
name-calling all of that boys way
outpace girls there's some data
suggesting that girls use relational
violence more exclusion you know that
kind of thing but there's also data
showing auto boys do that too right so
it's more you know that pound-for-pound
a single a mean event as a very
different sort of set of repercussions
for girls than boys
they both probably should take a page
out of the other's book you know that we
don't want boys to just be trying to
stomach pain right we want them to reach
out and talk to somebody and for girls
sometimes we do need to say I think you
need to let this one drop you know I
think continuing to discuss this may not
actually help make it better at this
point
so we see those distinctions what you
were asking about reminded me of
something I've always observed so I have
this private practice I've had for a
very long time and it means I get to see
rare events occur more than once and and
one pattern is I think is doesn't happen
that often but I've gotten to see it
over over my time is um when a high
school girl and boy end up in a really
powerful romance you know which happens
you know it happens where maybe they're
juniors are seen
not completely anak no it's not it's not
it still happens and and then it's time
to go to college and you know which
stinks right cuz there's really no good
outcome because you know they wouldn't
have broken up but staying together is
not so good
and so they decide to uncouple you know
they decide they're not gonna be
together and what I watch is that the
girl has all these girlfriends that she
can go to for support you know about
about the end of this relationship and
losing what it means and the boy keeps
coming back to the old girlfriend to try
to get the support he needs because he
does not have an emotional support
network of guys and that I often think
when I'm always hearing about this from
the girl's perspective so I thought you
know I'm not quite sure that what I'm
hearing is the whole story by any
measure but I often get the sense that
for him it was the first really intimate
relationship whereas she has him and
also for girlfriends he's well versed in
relationships and then she's like why is
he coming back to me he doesn't have
anyone else that he does that he's done
that with and I always I'm just a confor
those boys and you know when I'm hearing
the girls side and she's like oh you
call keeps calling and I don't know what
to do cuz we said we're not gonna be
together and I'm thinking like oh that
poor guy like I don't know that he has a
network of intimacy's that he can fall
back on and I think it all opened up
with her you know I think that that was
when he really had his first and what
happens to that boy if he can't find a
healthy you know external party with him
to process this like if it just
continues to be internalized what I
usually see is that he kind of blows it
up right that he goes and makes out with
her good friend you know or something
like that it takes a very distracting
turn right like and usually not a good
one right but but that it that it did it
he acts out in a way and this is this is
you know sort of a pattern we've
observed for a long time that when when
girls are in distress they're more
likely to collapse and on themselves
thus the higher rates of anxiety and
depression when boys are in distress
they're more likely to you act out get
themselves in trouble so now it seems
like a lot of the issues
that we spent a lot of time talking
about with respect to the socialization
of teenage girls could be addressed by
creating a healthier way for young
adolescent boys to communicate right
like wouldn't this would ameliorate a
lot of the problems that then spill into
the the girls community so I think about
this a lot right you know I think about
so you be used the term toxic
masculinity right and and I know there's
such a thing I'm I'm cautious I can't
imagine that's the term that feels good
for guys to hear you know I like I'm
mindful of that like and and I you know
as a psychologist I'm always on the side
of not trying to trigger defenses you
know not trying to get people's back up
so I've been thinking a lot about the
sixth and seventh grade boys who are
probably having a lot of the same
thoughts and feelings as every sixth and
seventh grade boy but we'll do none of
the stuff that we don't it isn't healthy
right we're in no way engage in what we
call toxic masculinity you know they're
good guys and they're they're you know
they got crushes but they don't call
people names and and I've I've gotten
really interested in those guys I'm like
what's working for them
like what's the story then because again
like the you know the three guys were
acting like jerks in the class you know
they get a lot of attention and they got
a lot of power but I um I think there's
I don't know boys like I know girls but
I was talking about this with them I
could friend of mine a guy who has three
brothers two brothers and I was saying I
think oh I imagine all six and seventh
grade boys or like if they're
heterosexual they're like thinking about
sex a lot and thinking about you know
but they're not all acting you know so
so inappropriately and he said oh yeah
he said my brother was in trouble one
time when he was in the seventh grade
he's had trouble with my dad about maybe
not taking it enough paying enough
tension at school they're being serious
enough at school if he said my brother
at seventh grade said to my dad I know
but it's hard cuz I'm like I'm thinking
about boobs all the time you know
okay but I don't think this was a kid
who was doing any of that stuff so I'm
actually a little my mind is going these
days to the question and I don't know
that I'm equipped to answer it of what's
working for the guys who maybe do have
real friendships with other guys in the
seventh grade and you don't talk about
women in that way and aren't playing
smear the queer you know at recess and
wouldn't do any of those things like
what's their story you know it because
that's I think that's most guys yeah and
I think I think what happens is you know
I would I'd probably consider myself one
of those guys like you're when you're
talking I'm thinking like what was my
experience in sixth or seventh grade I
mean in seventh grade I was bullied I
was quiet I internalized you know
whatever trauma I was experiencing and I
just was like an island unto myself and
I think it stunted my emotional
development but there weren't a lot of
healthy emotional outlets for processing
those tricky you know thoughts and
experiences that you're having at that
time yeah yeah I just wish we were
paying more attention to the kids were
getting it right because something's
working
but you mentioned being you know on the
receiving end of that stuff right so
then there's work to be done there for
the kids who aren't doing it but or you
know our uh-huh
I haven't having to deal with it you
know and and I bet you could probably
divide a class right two kids who are
perpetrating that stuff perpetrating
kids were on the receiving end of that
stuff kids who are have no part in it
and what you'll also find is there's a
fourth group which is kids who are both
bullies and victims you know that that
also mm-hmm that that's a category
always bullies and victims meaning they
be on both sides of that right right
right
yeah yeah well that's the kind of
classic abuse cycle is it not I think
that that's what we tend to see but I at
the same time you know seventh graders
are goofy like they're just goofy it's
the worst grade is a worse it's a bad
yeah it's a bad what's just that is
not a good year and
and I said an untangled like you know I
just we cannot find a cure for the
seventh grade like we just you know we
just were still thinking about it all
the time I have seen perfectly good kids
who have no reason in their history to
be mean accidentally discover how much
power mean this gives them and get drunk
on it as seventh graders so I do think
sometimes kids are bringing to school
repertoires that are lived at home right
where they they see how you can talk to
people and they think that's an OK way
to talk to people at school I think that
sometimes happens I have also seen it's
just kind of dawn on a seventh-grade
girl that like wow if I say something
mean about her everybody wants to hang
out with me you know and that in that um
cognitive incapacity to reflect very
much on all of it she just goes with it
you know and then and you know usually
by ninth or 10th grade they've got
enough perspective that they're like
well like I probably shouldn't treat
that person that way but 7th grade it's
just exciting um there's a a New Yorker
cartoon I saw a million years ago and
these two guys walking up Capitol Hill
holding briefcases and one says to the
other um how do I know I have power if I
don't abuse it yeah and I'm like that's
that's great like that is like that is
the cartoon of seventh grade yeah played
out in the halls of government yes yes
well let's bring it back to the home I'm
interested in and how we as parents can
develop better strategies around how to
communicate with the young people in our
lives to you know hopefully set our kids
on a better trajectory or help them you
know correct whatever you know it'll be
gotten passed they found themselves on
like this is just a constant
you know source of learning for me of
you know missteps and self Corrections
and trying to get it right and of course
you know often not getting it right well
I would say that a lot of my writing is
a
the invariable an inevitable friction
that is just part of raising kids and
and I I think I've really committed
myself to writing about it because I
feel like it doesn't get talked about
enough right so so I write a monthly
piece for the New York Times and you
know and I've done pieces titled you
know know your teenager doesn't hate you
it's just summer right and why teenagers
are allergic to their parents right and
why teenage girls roll their eyes you
know and I and I really enjoy trying to
illuminate all that's going on
developmentally that feels extremely
personal to the parent but it's not
about the parent it's it's this
developmental path this is like sorry to
enter yeah but like this is Julie's
constant thing with me because I will
personalize it and she's she's like a
Jedi at being neutral and like just
dissipating whatever tension there is by
you know making a joke or whatever and
she's like you've gotta like it's not
about you it is not about you you're
along for the ride but this is not about
you but the reason I I think I found
myself in this space is I worry that
there can be this this sense that one
gets from reading about parenting that
if you just do it this way you're if you
just say this magic set of words then
your childhood do is you ass gonna be
charming company and admire you and like
and I feel like no no no no it's a huge
mess and you're doing the best you can
and she's doing the best you can she can
and you know occasionally there will be
like wildly delightful moments of
parenting and the rest is life yeah but
then it's so in that mess here's what I
here's what the data tell us like if you
if you want it to come out well in the
end which we all want it to come out
well in the end the big picture stuff
and we have you know I mean we've been
studying parenting and outcomes for you
know 80 years and you throw all the
studies in a hopper right and you and
you get them to drop out the major
findings if you are warm with your kids
and if you have structure the rest will
sort itself out so there has to be a
sense of I like you I want to be with
you I enjoy your company I think you're
neat right if you can get that in place
and then if you can have rules that
matter that are understood to be
important for a family life or
understood to be part of how we do
business in this home and enforce those
and and be a predictable parent I I
actually I think we talked about being
consistent a lot in parenting I would
not use that word I would say you need
to be predictable and how you do things
because you can be predictable and
pretty weird and your kid can completely
work with it because they know versus if
you are unpredictable that actually
really hamstrings kids or if you you
sporadically enforce a barrier boundary
yeah that really does kids in and that's
actually where you know the stories like
parent parental alcoholism really you
know when when we drill down on what you
know at the granular level why that made
life so hard is it like they never knew
what they were getting right whereas my
own mom had I had no curfew as an
adolescent you know she was like oh come
on when you come home right if I left a
sink a spoon in the sink you know a
nuclear reaction alright so so like
there is no like logic to the relative
right but it was not I knew the
deal right so you just don't leave
aspirator sink and you know you come
home when you please and and and so I
would just say to parents you know if
you can be one if you can have rules and
consistently reinforce them it and be
predictable in your reaction to things
things will be alright and and that I
would say especially my work around
adolescence in my efforts through
untangled and under pressure to really
detail what the girls side of it right
sort of the back like what's happening
inside of her I would say it largely is
to help parents not take the whole thing
so personally know that parents feel
like their teenage daughter broke up
with them you know I know and they feel
like she's doing their adolescence to
them you know and that that is a a very
narcissistic it's natural but it's very
narcissistic because it's it's coming
from this place of the parent wanting
the parents emotional needs met through
the
child which is unfair to the kid and
just not healthy right it's definitely
not healthy the problem is up until
about age nine they're good for that yes
you know like your eight-year-old thinks
you're awesome and funny and wants to
come to the grocery store with you and
likes to cuddle you know so I think
there's a lot of joy in that and and I
want there to be a lot of joy in that I
think that I've always sort of have
these sweet conversations like I'll give
a talk to a group of parents and and
some mom will come up to me and she'll
say you know my daughter's 11 and I
think we're gonna be okay and I and I
know exactly what she's thinking if
she's thinking like she's not gonna turn
on me like them badly before girls I see
at the mall you know and I go yeah it's
okay you know it's okay and I and I just
think um you know I I try to write
anywhere I can just about you know know
it's at 11:00 they will close their
bedroom door and it will have nothing to
do with you mm-hmm this is about their
need to start to establish their
autonomy in the utterly bizarre scenario
where they have to become independent
while living at home right right one of
the things I did with Mathis our 15 year
old over the years when she was younger
is to joke about this impending change
like I would say see how great we're
getting along and it's now it's always
gonna be like this right so what you're
not gonna be one of those people who at
1314 is gonna slam the door in my face
we're gonna remember this moment right
now right she would laugh again and we
laugh about it now because you know she
does what fifteen-year-old girls do and
I was like remember when we had that
conversation yeah we can laugh like it
dissipates the tension of all of it but
to get back to something you said a
moment ago which is this idea of if I
just say the right thing and you know
there's a control mechanism at play
there that is highly dysfunctional and
it's about trying to make that child
conform to your world view of what you
think they should do and be and that's
not good right it's not and it's also
not developmental so what I'm
is the thing I'm so grateful for in my
training is that I was really trained as
a developmental psychologist he
basically said okay and you know at zero
to 12 months like here's what's
cognitively happening for the kid and
you know and I can do that for every
year so sometimes people will call me on
the phone or start talking to me never
like my daughter buh buh buh buh and
I'll say after the first puzzle say like
well how old is she like I can't process
data about kids without knowing the
exact developmental box they're in and
so um 13 year olds right are in this
extremely unique developmental box where
their brains are wildly dysregulated you
know where they're very cocky they're
very easily overtaken by emotion as a
function of neurological development
right there's the it just they are
caught in this moment where their
emotion centers have been upgraded but
their perspective maintaining centers
have not been upgraded and so if they
become upset the whole system
you know crashes and what my work feels
like my main aim is so that parents know
the developmental box they're in so when
they're 13 year old walks in the door
and they say one word and the kid loses
it or you know has some sort of meltdown
they can actually have the developmental
perspective of oh okay they're having a
you know a meltdown because
neurologically they can't it's not that
this is about something you know
something about me and then you try to
offer some strategies for getting
through that moment you know um so I I
would say what I aim you know hopefully
is is that you know I think the the work
that psychologists can do is the more we
can just give parents a perspective that
is neutral developmental you know 12
year olds are like this 13 year olds or
14 year olds are like that you don't it
doesn't always map perfectly to honor
your own kids ages then parents can
adjust but kids are a moving target
right and and unless you have a good
memory for your own adolescence or you
know good access to developmental and
information it's very easy to take them
at face value but that's not really uh
appropriate but the more you can do that
then you can on
you can sort of uncouple from the
emotional trigger and deep personalize
it right we all have our buttons and you
know our kids know where those buttons
are and they know how to push them and
you know it's taking a lot of a lot of
work on on my part a lot of meditation
and mindfulness work and work that I do
in recovery to just be able to have the
capacity the facility to pause when
agitated not just react and get
emotional about something but just you
know take a beat take a moment and try
to you know cogitate the the neutral you
know best next thing to say or do I
think that's awesome right that's one
reaction I also I want parents to know
like it's okay to get mad at your kids
you know not in a mean nasty way but I
think you know if you don't always have
the wherewithal to not react I think
another way to look at those moments is
to think um you know no one's gonna ever
think our kids are as cute as we think
they are right and and I think there's a
lot to be said for learning at home that
you know if you're a jerk people aren't
gonna like it you know and they're gonna
get angry sometimes or they're not gonna
want to be with you and so you know in
my own parenting I remember when I had
toddlers so two daughters I would get
mad you know eventually toddlers may get
really mad right and and I I learned to
say to my daughters you know what I'm
actually getting mad right like I'm
asking you repeatedly to do this thing
and I know I'm being patient but I want
you to I'm getting mad and and I'm gonna
start to be mad you know if this goes on
and then when if they continued to be
annoying then when I got mad I felt like
you had fair warning right like so it
wasn't out of the blue so I think
there's a place for anger in family life
if a kid has really been incredibly
provocative and the parent is
predictable right and they know what's
coming I also think there's a lot of
value and apologizing to kids when we
screw up right so say we blow it right
and and they didn't have a calming to me
there is no there's a lot of power and
there's a lot of beautiful research on
about rupture and repair right there's a
lot that happens in a relationship when
a parent comes back to a teenager and
says you know what I overreacted and I
owe you an apology and I am sorry
there's there's a real there's real
growth that happens when parents can do
that what parents can't do is they can't
keep doing it repeatedly right like I
mean that that's where it can fall apart
but I'm definitely a sort of the brand
of psychologist who feels like let me
give you five options for how to react
to a kid because it's gonna depend on so
many contextual factors so sometimes you
may be able to be reserved sometimes you
might just come at and they shouldn't be
surprised because they always know
that's gonna get you going and sometimes
they didn't have a comment and you're
gonna apologize you know but they are
all are available and in the course of
the millions of interactions we're gonna
have we're gonna need them all yeah and
those millions of interactions you know
there's there's there's there's a
scientific way of kind of approaching
that and then there's a very kind of
intuition based you know artistic way of
approaching it's like this dance right
and you have this beautiful analogy of
the swimming pool
I think kind of encapsulates that can
you kind of elaborate on that so this
isn't untangled and it grew out of my
observation that you know teenagers work
to become independent that's their job
the piece that seems to really get
parents is that they don't become just
slightly more independent each day you
know they don't just become a little bit
further and more autonomous each day
that a typical pattern is that um you
haven't heard from your teenager for
three days right or she's barely
acknowledged your existence and then
something goes wrong right and she's
very very upset and so then she comes
seeking the parent right and it may be
that she's needing physical comfort or
just wants to talk and wants to share
things it is not unusual in these
moments where there is actually a
physical like they're draping themselves
on you or like cuddling near okay so the
girl may be upset I know the parents
through the words like ah you know I'm
like loving it absolutely loving it um
and then and then she's gone again right
and so in observing this happening in
families the the metaphor I came up with
and it's slightly belaboured but it does
work really well
um is that the girl is like a swimmer
and the water is the world and the
parents are the wall that holds the
whole thing together there the pool and
swimmers want to be out in the water
right I mean they want to be out in the
pool and and with they want to put with
other swimmers they want to be gaining
strength and I've keeps thinking about
this metaphor you know when you're in
the middle of the pool you're not
thinking about the edge of the pool like
that's the furthest from your mind right
but then they get dunked or they get
exhausted or something and they had that
feeling you know I think all of us maybe
can remember this from swimming lessons
or they're like I'm drowning I'm
drowning right so they come scrambling
for the wall which is the parent and
they cling to the parent to get their
breath back okay so the parents loving
it I think that usually what happens for
teenagers is they do have that swimming
pool lesson experience where they're
like oh wait never mind I'm fun you know
and so then goodbye guys but I think
actually it becomes a pretty abrupt
goodbye because they're like I'm fine
and oh my god I'm in my mother's bed
right like this is so awkward
so they shove off right there they push
off in a pretty abrupt way so they may
say and I love this about teenage girls
even my own like that margin of like I'm
mean but not punishable commentaries you
know that they make so they may say like
wait did you wear that today right how
you know or something like that like
it's just with like a razor razor blade
precision yes yes and so the parents
repeated experiences I have no idea
where you are
oh my god you're letting me cuddle you
you just kicked me in the stomach right
and it's sort of on repeat and so um
what I wrote that up for is not because
I'm like and so here's the magic
solution to prevent this because you
actually cannot prevent this and I
actually don't want you to prevent this
though I don't think you kids should be
rude you know if they say something
really rude you can say like that's rude
you know we don't talk like that
um what I wanted was for parents and
this is exactly what we were talking
about - no this this decor like this is
what's happening this is not meant as a
as a personal rejection your daughter
can breathe again
Nashes on you know to her next thing and
so what my aim in in offering parents is
metaphor it was so that they would save
her when they did get to have those
moments and
I got this wonderful letter I get
letters which is like really fun from
readers like handwritten it's like you
know sometimes typed you know it's like
a really fun thing and I had this mom
write me a while back and she said you
know I bought untangled from my daughter
but of course 80% applied to my son and
she said I want you to know boys do that
swimming pool thing too and and what she
described she said I have a 17 year old
son and every once in a while had come
in the den where my husband and I
watched television and he will lay his
head in my lap and ask me to rub his
back right and she said and then he'll
stand up and leave without a word and
she said that just happened how can I
blow this and she said and then I read
your book and I realized what was
happening and she said so now and he
comes and he lays his head in my lap she
said well I I savor it and she said and
my husband looks over at me and he
mouths the words swimming pool to her oh
yeah
and she said and I just I know it may
last 90 seconds and I'm just gonna enjoy
it and I know that when he stands up to
leave it's because he feels ok again not
because he doesn't like me and that's
your job yes to help that person feel ok
you're this safe harbor and the pool
doesn't exist without the wall but it's
not about the wall yeah
so it's a super interesting yeah I loved
that way yeah and I think it speaks to
this need that we all have as parents to
let go of you know we always we all we
we romanticize these moments in the past
and we have this urge for it to go back
to that way and the more we can kind of
let go of that and just understand that
that's that's not what this is about
this is about you know trying to prepare
them for the world it is and and and I
do have thought a lot jocke with my own
15 year old daughter about like the idea
of them becoming independent on and
autonomous while still thoroughly
dependent I I joke with her sometimes I
call it The Impossible Project
mm-hmm and and I I was I remember one
day she decided she really liked Beyonce
at around age 13 and okay well I've
liked Beyonce for a really long time
right and so you're bonding thing well
no no
no because I because I couldn't like me
off anymore cuz she like Beyonce and I
remember we were in the kitchen and we
had music playing and it was like a
Beyonce song and I was bopping to it and
she was like mom mom you know she wanted
me to stop and then in the next second
she's like oh can you open the cheese
you can't do this it's not cool alright
and then also can you please take care
of me and this right a child right right
and I just and I said oh this is the
Impossible Project like I sort of joked
with her about it but I do think like
let's take a minute and realize we are
saying like I want you to become a full
grown independent person while you live
under my roof by my rules and I Drive
you places and tell you what I don't
feel comfortable with you wearing like
how is that gonna be a smooth thing yeah
you know and and I guess that the reason
I like to articulate that is I'm so much
on the side of saying like this is
situational right this isn't that your
kids grown it up or you're screwing it
up it's that the design of this is gonna
create a lot of friction mm-hmm and
that's all right what's the best
strategy for navigating the kind of
emotional shutdown that occurs you know
the typical like how was your day fine
what happened nothing you know like well
the foot you know scrolling the phone
and you're like well I've just been
relegated to you know transportation for
this individual you know and there's
that sense of like all the intimacy you
know that we had is gone and now I I
don't even feel like I can like no
matter what I do I can't connect with
this person and there's a there's kind
of a despair that overtakes the parent
in that predicament
okay so there's like 14 answers to that
question okay so um the first is that
let us let us think for a minute about
what school is
okay so school is you take 20 to 30 kids
and you put them in a room and you
basically have them have a 45-minute
meeting and when that meeting is over
they go down the hall the same 20 or 30
kids have another meeting and they do
this all day every day for nine
consecutive months mm-hmm okay so no
grown-up could make it through that
right and kids are pretty gracious about
it and they get through it and they're
they don't
people very often and they you know they
sort of manage the day but school even
wonderful schools like it's a very
exhausting thing and so I think a lot
about that dynamic when the kid comes
home in the parent like how was school I
think it's like really like yeah you
want me to recount like this so I think
that that can be some of what's
happening I also think there's often a
dynamic where we think connect we think
about connecting in terms of how we have
in mind to connect right so the adult
approach to this is like I'm gonna ask
you questions and you're gonna answer
those questions right that's our agenda
right kids like and that's not my agenda
what is interesting to me is that often
later in the evening or close to bedtime
teenagers will often put forward a topic
or raise something and and parents don't
always pick it up right so we're like
hey I'm ready to connect you know and
then we want to connect in that kiddo
later say something like you know
something really weird happen in study
hall and the parents would be like right
do check my email right now yeah and so
but what is it's I think it's actually
pretty rare that there's a kid who's not
making those overtures I think that
often parents feel like no I I tried to
talk to you earlier alright that moment
is past that moment is power I'm busy
now I'm busy and the kid is actually
putting topics on the table that are not
being brought up picked up by the parent
either because the parent is distracted
or I mean human like I don't feel
critical about this but they're
distracted or the topic like they don't
even know how to engage it like it's
kind of a weird one you know or the the
teenager wants to show them the YouTube
video they're interested in like there's
stuff like that or um my my daughter's
like to watch fine compilations like I
find these so weird like I can't yet but
that's what they want to do with me and
they want me to look at them with them
and and I really try to not you're like
what why is this funny like I really
like I figure out my afflictions but
then here's the other thing I want to
say about this um in the vein of like
what connecting means to teenagers so
again like I've practice long enough
that I've had a couple rare things that
I've gotten to see a few times and so I
consult two days a week at the school
which means the girls know me well and
I'm sort of a piece of furniture for
them which I love and so it's happened a
few times
where girls will find me spontaneous and
be like dr. d'amour do you have a minute
and I'll say yeah and they'll come in
and their complaint is that their
parents are not home enough and
invariably the girl talking to me is
some ridiculously put together Junior
who could basically be a CEO of a
company at this point you know just one
of those kids and they'll complain their
parents are out a lot or really
preoccupied with another sibling who's
maybe having a hard time and the
complaint is earnest and genuine but
even as the girls sharing with me I'll
think if they were oh I'm pretty sure
you would not acknowledge their presence
but here the girl is saying that she
misses them and so that caused me to
write a piece a while back called what
do teenagers want Colin potted plant
parents right they actually don't want
us to ask so much with the questions
they don't really care what we did today
usually but they want us they are
leading boring middle-aged lives and
available should we be needed which I
know can sound very you know kind of
narcissistic on behalf of teenagers hmm
but I don't think we should give short
shrift to the idea that our physical
presence and our availability for them
is really important even if they are not
outwardly acknowledging it and the best
metaphor developmentally for this is
actually when we look at videos of
toddlers when we bring them into labs
and how they explore environments when
we're looking at attachment questions
securely attached toddlers will start in
their parents lab and they'll be all
these alluring toys around and then
they'll descend from the parents lap and
play with the toy and then they'll come
back and sit with a parent for a minute
and then explore further and then come
back and just touch the parents knee
without looking at the parent and then
explore further and so I think that's
happening again you know with this sort
of second individuation of adolescents
where in order to go out in the world
safely there has to be the sense of like
my base is here and I care where you are
I'm just not gonna talk to you that much
and don't want to ask me too many
questions so if you're home and
available
that's more connection than you realize
even if it's not what you had in mind
yeah that's we're interesting it's sort
of like you know the i-beams that that
hold up
you know the ceiling of the house or the
roof of the house we don't pay a lot of
attention to it but we need it to be
there and we're glad that it's there
yeah we're not gonna romanticize it no a
lot of dialogue around it but just yeah
that sense that that like just knowing
stability yeah and that that and it's
sufficiently valuable that teenagers
will come find me to complain about its
absence mm-hmm
and so where's the parent we think well
what do they care like you know you know
when I'm around they don't talk to me so
what's the big deal yeah so I really um
it's a great gift to give your kid if
you can just sort of be a genderless
with them and that actually for me feels
like the most important point which is
most adults when they're interacting
with teenagers have an agenda and their
teachers do their coaches do their
college counselors do like you know
they're something trying to make happen
and so often when we as parents are with
our kids like we're advancing an agenda
like so tell me about your day right or
and we can tell them to go do stuff and
they got to go do stuff I'm interested
in parents seeing the creation of a
genderless times as a critical form of
connecting with our kid yeah that's
that's um very reassuring and cool I'm
just thinking about the parent out there
who does only have a limited amount of
time with their kid like the dad who
works all day and then he's home and you
know there's only two hours before the
kid goes to sleep and the dad wants to
make sure that the homeworks done and so
it becomes agenda driven only because
there isn't enough time or bandwidth for
those moments of just letting all of
that go and being yeah so trying to
protect yeah yeah there's also ways
though even that dad or mom right you
know it's not unusual efforts I've got
two fantastic examples one is of a dad
where he and his daughter both enjoyed
pictures of the ocean you know in the
ocean so
he'll text her photos he comes across of
the ocean right you know and and that
little things throughout the day oh yeah
yeah it's all connected I'm thinking but
there's no like she doesn't have to
respond or anything like that another
day I love this um his college-age
daughter watches The Bachelor so he
started watching it so they'd have a
topic you know I'm like you know that's
like that's her agenda to it is cute and
it works you know and so then and he
said like so first we'll start the phone
call me did you see what happened right
and then invariably like she'll tell him
something that he was hoping to find out
about her life in college but like I'm
really interested in that kind of
creativity where you know the parent is
trying to get with the kids agenda as a
form of connecting yeah
yeah those little things that don't take
up a lot of time but indicate like hey
I'm thinking about you yeah and I know
what you like and I'm gonna try to like
it too I want to be curious about it my
youngest daughter she just loves animals
in nature so you know I said I'd do the
same thing I sent her a little text of
little animal videos on Instagram or
stuff like that when I see something
cute I think that matters
I think that matters and it's her agenda
so let's shift gears to we've been most
of what we've been talking about is
stuff that you covered in untangle and
in the writing that you do for the New
York Times and stuff like that but this
subject and the focus of the new book is
really pressure and anxiety yes
specifically with respect to adolescent
girls yes kind of epidemic that we're
now seeing around the pressure that
they're weathering so maybe flush that
out a little bit sure so um two things
inspired me to write this book one how
much people are not talking about stress
and anxiety you know I feel like I have
not had a conversation in the last 10
years around an adolescent where at
least one of those words wasn't present
if not at the center of the conversation
the other is that um there is a grand
canyon between how the popular culture
talks about stress and anxiety and how
psychologists understand stress and
anxiety and and it's causing part of the
problem so the
chap the first chapter in under pressure
articulates the clinical and research
based understanding of stress and
anxiety which is largely that
psychologists are pretty okay with these
that stress is a normal function
it occurs anytime there's growth it
occurs anytime we operate at the edge of
our abilities school is supposed to be
stressful there's a whole section of the
book good things are stressful you know
having a baby come into your house for
the first time is like wildly stressful
thing I'm stressful so it happens around
bad things stress that is not
overwhelming actually causes durability
it actually makes people able to weather
new difficult things I think about this
a lot you know forty-eight I think like
you know a real benefit of being
forty-eight is like stuff doesn't get to
me like I used to get to me you know
like what constitutes our crisis like
it's gotta be pretty bad you know and
that's as a function of having lived
right so there is such a thing as
chronic stress and such a thing as
traumatic stress and we don't like those
but so long as people are able to
recover from periods of stress largely
it makes people grow mm-hmm
same deal on anxiety it is a normal and
healthy and protective function it is an
evolutionarily installed system to alert
us to threats we get anxious if we're
driving in someone near us is swerving
we get anxious if we're procrastinating
and we need to get going on our work
it's an alarm system that that does keep
us on track and keep us safe it can
break it can go off all the time for no
reason
it can go off way out of proportion you
know kid having a panic attack about
about a quiz but I feel very strongly
about wanting to get that message out
there because with the whole sale
pathologizing of stress and anxiety
seeing it all is harmful and bad we are
running into the problem where kids are
now stressed about being stressed and
anxious about being anxious which is not
necessary exacerbating it in this
vicious circle absolutely and and I I do
you know I think a lot like how did this
golf emerge right between psychology is
really relative comfort
with stress and anxiety like we largely
see them as healthy and protective in
the cultures view and and I have started
to think like I think the well in this
industry may have a hand in this right I
mean I think that there's there's money
caught up in selling the idea that
you're supposed to feel calm and relaxed
all the time and I feel you know there's
a whole industry now built up around
this idea and then I think and I can
start to sound a little weird Lee
conspiracy theory about this but I don't
think okay so then say I've bought this
idea
right that I'm supposed to feel calm and
relaxed most of the time and then I get
up and I have any regular day right now
I'm gonna think well now I need a
solution to the fact that I feel
stressed I don't feel like that yoga
girl on Instagram who looks all blissed
out well she's the CEO of three
companies right exactly so now they'll
sell you a solution they're not feeling
that way right so so I I mean this is
where this is like my outer limits of
like weird thinking about this but
sometimes I think like I feel like I
almost want to rent like those planes
with banners behind them you know and
fly them over major American cities and
and my banners would say something like
like hey everybody like you're not
supposed to feel all that great that
often you know like if you occasionally
yes but not all day every day well that
reminds me a lot of the work that Susan
David it's done who's been on the show
and you know around emotional agility
and just being resilient and it's not
about avoiding stressors it's about
learning how to you know navigate them
and process them and you have this you
know you analogize it to weightlifting I
mean as an athlete it's sort of like you
welcome stress in your life stress is
the only way that you get better at
anything yes and it expands your
capacity to do more work you get
stronger emotionally mentally and also
physically so these are things that that
we need in order to CRO so it's not
about you know removing them from the
equation but I'm wondering whether you
know there's this statistic that were
we've seen an increase something like 55
percent in the stress and anxiety among
adolescent girls with no relative
increase among adolescent boys so is
this a
a social perception is it that vicious
cycle of feeling bad about being
stressed and creating more stress is
there something new and unique and
different that's happening with
adolescent girls now that's culturally
created that is chronic and malignant in
a way that we have to address it in new
ways so I think is probably like D all
of the above right so I do think for
everyone
culturally the misunderstandings about
stress and anxiety are making things
worse
and I do feel like I'm on this this
mission to try to clarify the
professional understanding okay but then
you do see these jumps for girls that
we're not seeing for boys and I think
there's stuff going on right and this is
really what the rest of under pressure
is about so chapter one is like here's
how stress and anxiety really work and
then chapters you know 2 through 6
really sort of go through the layers and
some of the layers that I think are
unique for girls are the intensity of
their social interactions right I mean I
we do see you know kind of back to our
earlier conversation though boys may
suffer anymore silence they also tend to
feel better faster right things die down
quicker whereas girls strategies for
managing social stuff can lead to kind
of an exacerbation so I talked in my
mail yes we're still on this still
really like I so I talked in
under-pressure about helping girls
manage conflict much more effectively
than usual and also giving them
permission to not engage in a conflict
to just let something drop which we
don't do I talk an under-pressure
about the amount of harassment they're
dealing with it's right I think that's a
very real factor and I think that may be
worse right I mean I think that may be
worse i again porn me be part of that
story
um i talk about girls at school the
landscape for girls at school is such
that they are crushing it girls are
incredibly good students they are by
some statistics like 70% of high school
valedictorians are gonna be girls they
are doing extremely well the boys are
not doing as well as they should be but
girls are putting tremendous pressure on
themselves academically and I think
that's part of why
we're seeing these rising rates of
stress and anxiety in a way that's
different in the generation that
preceded them
I do think what's happened as school has
changed in a generation so what I can
say with confidence as I feel like
largely high school has come College has
come to high school and high school has
come to middle school so what we're
seeing now is that for very ambitious
high school students they're taking an
average of eight ApS if not thirteen
yeah so when we were in high school that
wasn't even an option right so you
combine a highly conscientious student
who girls also engage in very
inefficient study strategies and we let
them you know they recode their notes
and color code and all of this which
usually is unnecessary you combine
something like that with eight APs and
you're gonna get you know chronic stress
like you can't avoid it and then I do
worry about the culture and its impact
on girls you know their expectations
about being attractive and being
agreeable and you know and so I think
there's a special set of pressures yeah
everything is heightened everything's
heightened boys suffer boys suffer in
ways that I don't know nearly so well as
I know the story about girls but I do
think there's there are real factors
that bring stress and anxiety up
disproportionately for girls let's talk
about the language piece it is
interesting you know and and somewhat
counterintuitive also some of the things
you write about with respect to you know
how girls talk about themselves and what
the culture thinks about how that should
shift or change depending upon your
perspective so in terms of like girls
speech and our yeah these thing of it
this is really I loved writing this up
so one thing that you will see in the
culture around trying to help empower
girls is guidance to them about how they
should speak right and and it's not
unusual to see articles like you know
telling girls not to apologize so much
you know and not to use hedges which is
a any any linguistic form where you kind
of soften what comes next
or just or like or things like that and
the rationale for this guidance is that
and and I'll quote Naomi Wolf who wrote
a piece on these lines you know that the
girls are undermining their own power
you know that they need to use their
strong female voice in order to sort of
achieve a more equal place in the
society which you know it makes it
sounds good
it sounds good like that you know this
is a very plausible argument but then
along comes this academic feminist
linguist named Deborah Cameron who whose
work I'm really interested in and she's
at Oxford she's not someone who is known
well in in the popular culture in the
same way Naomi Wolf is and she has taken
this up very aggressively and wrote
actually very sharp retort to Naomi Wolf
about Naomi's piece around saying like
girls shouldn't use vocal fry' that you
know sound like the Kardashian you know
and they shouldn't use up talk the
rising inflection at the end of a
sentence and here's what Deborah Cameron
says back she says okay first of all if
you look at the data there is no such
thing as girls speech when we look at it
statistically girls and boys and men and
women speak they use the same patterns
it is true often though that people hear
it more if it comes from the stereotyped
group so there are studies that look at
relinquish record speech and then play
it back and if it's a girl you'll hear
her say like a lot more even if she says
that at the exact same rate as as a boy
and then Deborah Cameron does point out
there's a there's a tiny juncture girls
drive language change adolescent girls
drive language change
so there's when language is changing
which is always changing there's
sometimes a moment where girls are using
a speech form that people aren't using
other bit everybody else isn't using and
then we all adopt it so we all start to
use they're the leaders they're the
leaders that was that how that's
interested they're just at the vanguard
of language change they're the most
innovative they're that you know like I
mean and one of the best things about
being with teenagers is like I get all
the new slang right so I don't know if
this has come to California but um extra
have you heard this I don't know it's
the best you know Blake please
so it's a the best it's the best like
it's basically like they'd be fine they
just need to take it down a notch
they'll be like oh my god so and so is
being so extra about this right yeah
it's brilliant it's absolutely brilliant
right so this is like this is the kind
of innovation that girls give us but for
the most part there's no such thing as
female speech yeah okay so then if you
just kind of keep following this out
then the next question is okay but even
if girls even if say there were such a
thing that you know that men are bold
and direct and women need to be that way
too we want to be careful about that and
here's a here's a great story this is
not an under-pressure I had this
conversation after I'd written it but it
just it captured it so well so a friend
of mine
Kevin is a federal prosecutor so he is
in charge of a large group of young
lawyers whose job it is to asking
questions all day and he and I were
talking about this and he said you know
the male lawyers will come to my office
and just ask their question and my
female lawyers will come and say do you
have a minute right and he was
reflecting on this and he was thinking
you know the men should do what the
women are doing right it's actually not
appropriate for them to just it's like
the women are more so rather than
thinking about it in terms of the women
or the girls needing to change their
behavior pattern their speech patterns
the men are the ones who in this in this
context yeah yeah but then he also said
the guys are getting more their
questions answered so it's working for
the guys right yeah it's it's it's both
really I mean because if the culture
doesn't change to compel men to change
that that you know tick then women
should adopt that Naomi Wolf approach
well let's think that so here's where it
gets interesting again maybe they should
we do not want to promise to teenage
girls that it will work for them the way
it works for the guys right we also have
tons of data showing that if a girl were
to do the equivalent like just start
with her question the culture sees that
differently than when the guy does it
the guy is being bulled direct a sort of
she's being pushy annoying and brash so
what I say to teenage girls I say I'm
not saying don't I'm not saying don't
get angry don't be direct don't be a
sort of don't be bold I'm not gonna
promise you it's gonna work for you the
way it's gonna work for a guy so if you
do it like you should be ready to rumble
like you may need to write and I worry
that often in the you know people to
interact and use your strong female
voice the the implicit message is
because this will be successful for you
right we actually don't have the data
suggesting that we have the opposite
okay B here's where Deborah Cameron
brings at home she's like you know what
Naomi instead of going after how girls
speak she and Deborah Cameron says like
you're doing the work of the Patriarca
for it why don't we go after the
structures that go after how girls speak
and this is actually a well-worn pattern
that we sometimes go after a group by
going after how they talk right that I'm
criticizing their language and the best
example and I didn't include this in
under pressure because I feel like you
need the the to hear it so how that
really makes sense is um so that vocal
fry' like the oh my god know that
everybody hates hates hate hate some
girls do it okay so this is also
conventional among upper crust British
males so if you think about Hugh Grant
haha yeah it is the exact exact same so
funny right but it's such a good example
it's not about the speech it's about the
speaker right so a woman does oh my god
and we think she sounds like such a
dingbat and we can't stand it and then
Hugh Grant does his oh my my and it's
not brown it's so charming and so so the
so I basically like I make a mess of all
of this right and I could ask us to
revisit it in a way where I land is hey
and everybody needs a verbal toolbox
everybody needs a really elaborate
repertoire for communication because
what is more complicated than
communication right even nonverbal
communication there's an incredibly
complicated thing so what I say to girls
is like you should all have your hammer
right if you're in a bar and someone
touches your butt like you should be you
know ready don't really put them in
their place and then you should all have
your tweezer where you say do you have a
minute like I have a question for you
right and what I say to them is your job
is to get the job done and to have a
wide enough communication repertoire to
make it happen
and my favorite way to show them how
shrewd and tactical they already are is
to say you know how you ask your parents
for something that you know they don't
want to give you and they'll like smile
no yeah they're I mean they're like huge
it's ooh boyos for that and often it
involves a lot of the speech patterns we
criticize words like dad yeah I'm so
sorry to bother you but right ok this is
not a girl being weak this is a girl
being an absolute ninja right in this
moment and so I'm just really interested
in crediting girls for how nuanced and
sophisticated they are with language and
then of course there are girls who abuse
like and who abuse I'm sorry
and and then I think with them we say
like what's it about like what purpose
is it serving for you what else could
serve that purpose yeah I mean that's
the only kind of pushback that was going
on in my mind you know from a
psychological perspective the words that
are consistently coming out of your
mouth are a reflection of your interior
life and how you feel about yourself and
when your default tape is deferential
and you know as if you're you know
apologizing for taking up space
your words are going to reflect that
mental you know disposition and that's
what really needs to be addressed we
need to look into it but I would say
let's be curious not critical right
let's let's ask her you know you say I'm
sorry a lot like talk to me about it and
I have yet to meet a girl over age 14
who can't give you a really interesting
answer to that kind of question you know
they can reflect on it and it becomes
you know habits or ticks which they can
change when we're thinking about and
talking about the stress and anxiety on
young people specifically girls what are
your thoughts on this college admissions
scandal because and the reason I'm
asking is that you know I'm interested
in how much of this stress and anxiety
is being created by the parents so if we
hold on to the idea that there's 25
schools that we really want our kids to
go to we're gonna make it back and
there's just no getting around it the
statistics on getting your
kids into those 25 schools you know are
so dramatically different than they used
to be you know when kids say to me you
know however competent however
incredible they are you know when they
say like I'm looking at Harvard and Yale
and Princeton I'm like great and buy a
lottery ticket and like see ya come tell
me how it goes you know um we can make
it way way way better if we just say oh
my gosh there's literally thousands of
amazing American colleges you know and a
great fit for our kid is out there I
mean that would change everything yeah
and I thought it's different now that it
was 20 years ago it's totally different
and and it's but it's not a crisis that
it's very hard to get into these places
because there's so many excellent places
and one of the things I talk about it
under pressure is we have no data the
data do not tell us that professional or
economic success contribute to
well-being in adulthood everybody
assumes it does that's not actually what
matters and I think that's often what
drives this sense of like you have to go
to Harvard um the data say if you want
to don't well-being you cultivate good
relationships you do work that you find
meaningful and you feel that you're
skilled at that work which you actually
don't have to go to college for so I
think we could reframe it if we wanted
to
mm-hmm we're in this cultural moment now
where we're so worried about creating
these kinds of stresses and anxieties
that we're seeing that you know we've
perpetrated this kind of snowflake
culture where everybody gets a medal and
we don't want anyone to feel bad and
perhaps there's a good intention behind
that and one of those intentions very
well may be to ameliorate this stress
and anxiety so that we you know we're
we're not seeing it metastasize and
young people but we're seeing the
opposite result right yeah how do you
think about all of this um but I think
is we want Goldilocks stress right not
too big not too little but just right
and you're not gonna get it every day
but for sure we do not want to prevent
stress in children we want them to have
the inoculating function of having
something go wrong becoming quite upset
about it getting empathy and then
figuring out other
recover that will build their capacity
to weather difficulty
well the recovery pieces is the key
right like in the same sense of of an
athlete you need to repair yourself in
between your workouts you need to
recover you can't be in a state of
persistent chronic stress and I think
that yes that above and beyond anything
is why we're seeing these increased
rates right well so the truth is right
school for some kids is so different to
many ap yes and there's this never it's
gonna be Cummins during the summer
they've got to do something that looks
amazing on a college application essay
or whatever so then we get into
questions of chronic stress but for the
most part you know that the workout
metaphor the weightlifting metaphor is
ideal because it is it's like you do
something difficult you then you know
repair and regrow and are stronger than
you were I do think the other thing I
love about the weightlifting and
exercise metaphor is that sometimes
people get stuck because stress and
anxiety don't feel good and so then
there's a sensible then it can't be good
for you well no I mean exercising and
we're spec sure you'll get all that yeah
and also exercising at your limit
doesn't feel good right so and people
can remember that piece um and then yeah
we don't want to kind of keep going with
this idea that you're supposed to feel
so good all the time what are some of
the big mistakes that you see parents
making time and time again where you're
just like oh my lord if they just knew
if they just did it like this this would
be so much smoother um it's funny I
don't I'm really cautious about
criticizing parents cuz I love them and
I think they're working so hard one
thing I have thought about criticize no
no but here's something I'm really
curious about I we have not reckoned
with what it means that parents have
real-time updates on their kids moods
due to texting like I I think this is a
bigger hazard than we have reckoned with
kids are often through the day texting
their parents about this upset or this
disappointment or this annoyance and
parents are responding through the day
with you know with feedback or support
or suggestions or you know worse picking
up the phone and calling the school you
know my kids in the bathroom upset go
get her
you know that that's not an unusual
in the life of a school anymore and so I
would probably put at the top of the
list that we've slipped into a place as
a function of digital technology where
much longer and later into development
kids are using their parents for
emotional reassurance and sometimes like
fixing then we have ever before and and
I know this can't be right I know this
can't be right and I talkin under
pressure about a mom who came up with a
genius solution because she was getting
texts all day from her 14 year old and
of course like the mom's day was ruined
right cuz she was you know I've said and
and then the get the girl was you know
usually rejecting her suggestions anyway
you know so the mom got her daughter a
notebook a beautiful notebook and said
you know I want you to write in the
notebook everything you want to text me
during the day and then at night like if
you want to show it to me I'd love to
see it uh-huh and so often the girl had
no interest like the girl used it the
girl did it but she had no interest in
showing her mom what was in there
because it was over like you know
rearview mirror like she didn't care
anymore and I thought it was such a
beautiful half step you know saying like
I wanted I care and I'm interested I
don't want to know in real time you know
so I I would just ask parents to not go
lightly into that space of being an
emotional touch with their kid all day
yeah what you know how much information
is too much I don't like how you know
where where is that demarcation line the
DMZ between being involved in your in
your adolescents life in a healthy way
versus like well you don't need to know
everything that they're doing that
they're there is something healthy about
them you know having their own private I
actually am pretty fierce advocate for
adolescents privacy and you know once
had to become one in a digital age right
I mean you and I had a lot of privacy
just because our parents had no way you
know to know either physically where we
were or you know what we were like
curious about now I just like got on my
bike see you dinner
yeah yeah and we had whole worlds to
ourselves you know they didn't know how
we spoke to our friends they didn't know
a lot about our social networks unless
we chose to share so I think the other
thing that I'm curious about is what it
means I mean we are the first generation
of parents has had this volume of
information available to us on our kids
my general rule on this is you got to
know your kid in terms of how much
you're gonna know right so if you have a
kid who's super impulsive and getting
themselves into trouble all over town
I would I would keep that kid on a very
short leash we shouldn't have a lot of
information about them if you have a
pretty steady predictable level-headed
kid I would say unless there's smoke I
would not assume anything's on fire I
would give them cut them a wide berth
mm-hmm
one thing I'm finding myself saying a
lot to parents is that um I mean I've
been a practicing clinician for 25 years
like I honestly say I've never seen a
full-blown crisis arrive in 24 hours you
know that that usually there's there's a
run-up to something going wrong right
and and I would take off the table you
know like if your kid is attacked or
something like you know that but when
parents I sometimes worry that parents
have this sense maybe caused by the
media like you have to track all the
data all the time because there might be
a piece of information in there that's
gonna illuminate for you some terrible
problem you another never otherwise know
I feel like if your kids haven't dinner
with you on a pretty regular basis and
you're around and you're sort of present
in their lives it's pretty hard for them
to get very very far out of course
without you being aware something's
amiss you know we're all you know a
reflection of the experiences that we've
had and and we're kind of set up to
project those onto the people that we
love and my sense is that parents are
quite adept at projecting their neuroses
onto their kids and perpetuating
whatever cycle of dysfunction you know
created their own personal trauma and
then recreating it in those
relationships how can we help parents
develop a little more
self-awareness around that to prevent
those mmm that's a great question
me what you're talking about is probably
largely an unconscious process alright
so something that's hard to be self
aware of and I've seen it lots in my
time where a parent will come in first
to see me which I don't often do and
maybe it's cuz the kid doesn't really
want therapy and they'll describe this
it's kid who just sounds like a total
Hellraiser you know like they just
described this kid you like at all it
feels out of control and I have no idea
what's going on and then the kid comes
in and like it's like this really mild
can she's like I don't know what I did
you know and I do get the sense that
there's some sort of some ancient
history playing or like maybe the parent
themselves was sort of a wild teenager
or had a sibling who was secretly you
know kind of up to no good
um so I I guess I would say there's a
lot I think it's good to be thoughtful
about one's own adolescence right and
end one's own what did and didn't feel
like it worked well right and and to try
to be careful you know to not have one's
own potholes dictate you know how you're
driving now um I will also say this is
where it's really nice if there's more
than one grown-up involved in raising a
teenager right to have you know a couple
people you know and they can be divorced
remarried you know two moms two dads
doesn't matter um I would say that a lot
of good parenting happens when one
parent says to the other you know what
this is too hot to tell like this is too
loaded for me I need you to yeah take
the front line on this well that that
does do require a decent amount of
self-awareness ya know like this is an
area where I'm gonna do the wrong thing
too much baggage in this territory I I
think that's a real gift and then the
other thing and I talked about this
actually back in untangled like it's
okay for you to be neurotic you gotta
own it right so I I think it's okay for
parents to say you know what look if
it's gonna be about drugs and alcohol
like you know my history I don't handle
that well like that goes to your mom
right or you know like me and money like
I'm still working out my own erotic
stuff like uh huh I know that I do not
always respond to you in ways that are
rational about that so for the parent to
say I call it crazy spots in untangled
liked it
to own you know like yeah I've got my
own neurotic landscape and I know it
well and I'm also you know late 40s and
probably not changing but I'm not gonna
make this about you I know it's yeah
yeah one-one thing has been helpful to
me is to understand that how I react or
respond in a given situation is
essentially how I'm modeling behavior
for that child right so if I get angry
on modeling anger as a response to a
given set of parameters rather than
problem-solving or you know how to you
know reduce anxiety around something
that's anxiety producing or whatever and
just having that minute that little
moment of like okay what am i what's the
best way what's the best sort of
behavior that I can model for my child
in this kind of scenario I think that
really says it right it's it's what you
do well you can say all sorts of stones
if that doesn't line up with how you're
actually functioning in your
relationships and how you're actually
conducting yourself in life
first of all kids will just call you a
big fat hypocrite you know which don't
do that anyway but but also it's really
it comes down to what you choose in your
behavior yeah is what what kids will
most pay attention to I gotta let you go
you gotta go be on the Hallmark Channel
wonderful thank you so much you're doing
amazing works been very helpful to me
and my family and it's really powerful
and I think there's so much confusion
specifically around how to best raise
adolescent girls and the way in which
your demystifying it and providing
really helpful practical tactical
solutions for addressing the common
scenarios that we all face is really
great so thank you appreciate you are a
champion girls you are the girl
Whisperer the girl guru
I just hope to be their advocate yeah
and that's the thing you know as core
that I want to leave people with is this
you're not you're not like your
clinician but you're not looking at this
clinically like you really are a
champion of these girls and and you
I would just end it by saying my
fifteen-year-old daughter she's you know
hella challenging at times she's full of
energy but she is amazing she is like a
dynamo and has so many incredible
qualities and I feel like I'm just here
to like nudge and try to just channel it
in the right way but I don't want to put
that fire out
I want that fire to burn bright and the
sense that I get from you and your work
is that like you love these girls and
you want people to see how amazing they
are
and rather than perceive this period of
time as monstrous or difficult or
challenging to take all the pejorative
language you know strip stripped away
the pejorative language and just it's
like how can we champion what's amazing
about this and and really direct you
know these amazing girls soon to be
women into the best direction so that
they can be the leaders that we all want
and need them to be amen
yeah thanks thank you so much the book
is under pressure confronting the
epidemic of stress and anxiety and girls
in the book before that was untangled
guiding teenage girls through the seven
transition into adulthood awesome thanks
so much come back and talk to me again
sometime I'd love to are you working on
another book mm deep in the recesses and
right now you're you have to recover it
now yeah stress and anxiety all right
and the best way for people to reach you
sure website everything is dr. Lisa
d'amour Comdr
lis ad AM oh you are calm it's all there
cool check it out thank you so much
[Music]